es soll gewittern und stürmen dominik
jung was ist denn das für ein wetter im
juni das ist doch aprilwetter ja das
wetter ist schon ziemlich durchwachsen
seit ein paar tagen aber der regen tut
ja auch mal gut bisher war das frühjahr
sehr trocken gewesen
es brachte 50 prozent weniger
niederschlag und jetzt wird's auch mal
ein bisschen wärmer immerhin wieder also
heute bereits temperaturen bis zu 30
grad im äußersten osten und auch
teilweise im westen aber wir müssen
schon heute abend mit den ersten
schauern und gewittern rechnen vor allem
in berlin und brandenburg kann es heute
ordentlich schon zur sache gehen vor
allem auch morgen frühjahr ziehen aus
polen neue gewitterwolken heran und
morgen insgesamt in ganz deutschland
schwülwarm und einem breiten streifen wo
sich sehr warme und feuchte luftmassen
treffen da müssen wir morgen mit
teilweise heftigen gewittern rechte mit
starkregen mit sturmböen hagel und diese
gewitter ziehen nur sehr langsam und
deswegen gibt es morgen auf eine große
sturzgefahr
und auch der sonntag wird zwar warm sein
aber meist schwülwarm gewittrig und wir
müssen mit weiteren zum teil kräftigen
gewittern rechnen
gut da müssen wir alle gemeinsam durch
und dann kommt der sommer oder dominik
ja im grunde ist die wetterlage aktuell
schon sommerliche temperaturen wie
gesagt ist 30 grad morgen schwülwarm bis
33 grad und nächste woche geht es dann
im grunde ähnlich warm weiter
temperaturen dann meist so bis 25 grad
aber eben eine sehr hohe
luftfeuchtigkeit und ja das begünstigt
eben immer wieder diese gewitter also er
schon so ein leicht tropischer sommer
bei uns hier im land